Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History, which comes, not inappropriately, from Greece, or at least partly from Greece. The historian Herodotus tells the story of the Battle of Thermopylae, when the Spartans made their heroic stand against the Persian king Xerxes. And afterwards, when the Persians had wiped the floor with the Spartans, they asked a group of Greek deserters why there were so few Greeks at the battlefield. And the deserters supposedly replied that the rest of the Greeks were off at the Olympic Games watching the horse racing. The Persians asked what was their prize? What was the point? And the Greeks said the prize
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，本期节目非常应景地从希腊录制，或者至少有一部分是在希腊录制的。历史学家希罗多德讲述了温泉关战役的故事，当时斯巴达人对波斯国王薛西斯进行了英勇的抵抗。后来，当波斯人把斯巴达人打得落花流水时，他们问了一群希腊逃兵，为什么战场上只有这么少希腊人。据说这些逃兵回答说，剩下的希腊人都去参加奥林匹克运动会看赛马了。波斯人问，奖品是什么？意义何在？希腊人说，奖品
was a crown of olive leaves. And at that, the Persians supposedly cried out and gnashed their teeth and rent their garments and said, what kind of men are these that we're fighting against? They fight not for riches, but for glory. Now, another person who fights only for glory is my collaborator, Tom Holland, the translator of Herodotus' histories, no less. Tom, you're very keen on the Olympics, aren't you? I imagine you're dying to see the kickoff in Tokyo. You can't wait. Well, I'm very keen on the ancient Olympics. I actually find the modern ones a bit boring, to be honest. The synchronized swimming doesn't do it for you, or the powerlifting or whatever it is.
是一顶橄榄枝编成的冠冕。听到这里，波斯人据说大声痛哭、咬牙切齿、撕裂衣裳，并说道：这是什么样的人啊，我们在跟他们打仗？他们为荣誉而战，而不是为了财富。现在，另一个只为荣誉而战的人就是我的合作者汤姆·霍兰，他正是希罗多德《历史》的译者。汤姆，你对奥运会非常热衷，对吧？我想你一定迫不及待地想看东京奥运会开幕了。你简直等不及了。嗯，我对古代奥运会非常热衷。说实话，其实我觉得现代奥运会有点无聊。花样游泳对你来说没什么吸引力，还是举重什么的？
Not really. But the ancient ones are fantastic. And I'm incredibly jealous of you being in Greece right now as we record this and very grateful that you have broken off from Downing Retsina in the shade of Nice evening, flesh pots of Nafleon. In the flesh pots of the Peloponnese. So what I've actually done, exactly, I've broken off my holiday to be lectured by you about ancient religion and I said to my wife as she went off taking my son for an ice cream I said basically for the next hour Tom Holland will be just using the word sacral again and again and again I know exactly what's coming you know me you know me too well have you before we get on to the sacral quality of the ancient olympic games am I wow
倒也不是。但古代奥运会太棒了。而且，对于我们录制这期节目时你正身处希腊，我感到嫉妒万分，也非常感谢你在奈夫普利翁温柔晚风树荫下的雷齐纳葡萄酒酒香中抽身。在伯罗奔尼撒半岛的温柔乡里。所以我其实是这么做的，没错，我中断了度假，来听你给我讲关于古代宗教的课。我对我妻子说，当她带着我儿子去买冰淇淋时，我说基本上在接下来的一個小时里，汤姆·霍兰只会一遍又一遍、反反复复地使用“神圣的”这个词。我完全知道接下来会发生什么，你了解我，你太了解我了。在我们讨论古代奥运会的圣洁特质之前，我是不是——哇
am I going to major on that um have you you haven't actually been to olympia though this no although although i've never been although yesterday we went to namia um which is another games location and so there's a brilliant tunnel they've sort of reconstructed i think the tunnel that the athletes it's very like you know stepping onto the the field for the world cup final or something you go through the tunnel and you emerge into the stadium. And, yeah, you get a fantastic sense of what it was like. I mean, I know that's a silly thing to say because you don't really know what it was like,
我会在这个话题上大做文章吗？呃，你——不过你其实还没去过奥林匹亚，对吧？虽然——虽然我没去过，但昨天我们去了尼米亚，那是另一个运动会的举办地。那里有一条很棒的隧道，他们算是重建了那条隧道，运动员们……这就非常像，你知道的，走上世界杯决赛的球场或者诸如此类的情景，你穿过隧道，然后走出来进入体育场。而且，是的，你能对当时的感受有非常奇妙的体会。我知道这么说有点傻，因为你并不知道当时究竟是什么样的，
but you can sort of pretend anyway. I played the final countdown on my phone and got my son to run through the tunnel. Of course, there's nobody else here because of COVID. So it's brilliant. You get it all to yourself. And you win the crown. Exactly, the olive wreath. So you mentioned the Nemean Games.
但你至少可以假装一下。我在手机上播放了《最终倒计时》（The Final Countdown），并让我儿子跑着穿过隧道。当然，因为疫情，这里没有其他人。所以这太棒了。整个地方全归你了。你还赢得了桂冠。没错，橄榄花环。所以你提到了尼米亚竞技会。
Yeah, there were four, weren't there? Well, there were lots of games, but there were four games where basically, as in the story that you read from Herodotus, you get a crown. So they're called the Stephanic Games, Stephanos, being Greek for a crown. So the Nemean Games was basically ranked fourth.
对，当时有四个，对吧？嗯，有很多运动会有没有，但有四个运动会基本上就像你在希罗多德的故事里读到的一样，你能赢得一顶桂冠。所以它们被称为斯特凡尼克竞技会（Stephanic Games），Stephanos在希腊语中就是王冠的意思。所以尼米亚竞技会基本上排名第四。
Oh, you're telling me I've been to the – I didn't even get on the podium. Yeah, you didn't even podium. The Nemean Games and not even the bronze medal of games. That's so disappointing. Oh, my God. The Isthmian. The Isthmian is the bronze one. So that's at Corinth.
哦，你这是在告诉我我只去过——我甚至都没能站上领奖台。对，你连领奖台都没上。尼米亚竞技会甚至都不是铜牌级别的运动会。太令人失望了。天哪。伊斯米亚竞技会。伊斯米亚竞技会才是铜牌级别的。那是科林斯的。
Okay. Joining the Peloponnese, the southern kind of fork of Greece, to the mainland. Then the Pythian, which is at Delphi. And then the Olympian. And Pausanias, who is second century AD, basically he kind of writes travel guides. He writes a travel guide to Greece. The rough guide. The rough guide. And he says of the Olympic Games, they are the greatest, the greatest of games.
好吧。它连接了伯罗奔尼撒半岛（希腊南部的那个叉状半岛）和希腊大陆。然后是皮提亚竞技会，在德尔斐。最后是奥林匹亚竞技会。公元二世纪的保萨尼亚斯，基本上他有点像在写旅游指南。他写了一本关于希腊的旅游指南。《Rough Guide》（粗略指南）。《Rough Guide》。他对奥运会的评价是，它们是最伟大的，是最伟大的运动会。
And so that's why the modern games are named after them, because they are the pinnacle. Well, did Pausanias, you're not claiming that he invented the idea that the Olympic Games were the best? I mean, were they genuinely the best? He said that they rank first, they come okay if you if you win at the olympic games then that's absolutely the best although the mark of a really elite athlete and you know how keen i am on on elite sport is is to get the grand slam a bit like kind of tennis now you know you get and this is of course what uh what nero did? Well, I'm sure we'll come to this later on. That is what Nero did.
所以现代奥运会就是以它们命名的，因为它们是巅峰。等等，保萨尼亚斯——你不会是想说奥林匹克运动会是最好的这个主意是他发明的吧？我的意思是，它们真的就是最好的吗？他说它们排名第一，如果你赢得了奥林匹克运动会的比赛，那绝对是最好的。不过，真正精英运动员的标志——你也知道我对精英体育有多热衷——就是赢得大满贯，有点像现在的网球，你知道的，你会赢得……当然，这就是尼禄所做的事。嗯，我确信我们稍后会谈到这一点。尼禄就是这么做的。
But, and I know how much you've been looking forward to me using the word sacral. Yes, come on. Let's get it over with. Okay. So the key, really the fundamental difference between the modern Olympic Games, which as constituted now is basically about money. I mean, the reason that they're going ahead in a time of covid it's not because of the olympic spirit it's not because the amity of nations it's it's because of tv deals yeah well we're going to do the modern olympics aren't we in
但是，我知道你多么期待我使用“神圣的”（sacral）这个词。没错，来吧。让我们赶紧把它说掉吧。好的。所以关键在于，现代奥运会和古代奥运会之间最根本的区别——现代奥运会现在组建起来基本上是为了钱。我的意思是，它们之所以在疫情期间继续举办，不是因为奥运精神，不是为了国家间的友谊，而是因为电视转播协议。好吧，我们会在另一期播客中专门聊聊现代奥运会，所以我们可以讨论所有其中的龌龊事和政治内幕，但是——嗯，你提到的温泉关那个插曲，波斯人正在入侵希腊。这是一场巨大的危机。
another podcast so we can do all the sleaze and the politics of it but but the um the episode you mentioned with thermopylae the the Persians are invading Greece. This is a massive crisis. Holding the pass at Thermopylae is the best option the Greeks have to stop the Persian advance. But they don't go because of the games. And that's not because they're obsessed by sport, although they are. It's because the Olympic Games have this incredible status as something that is holy to the gods. And so, again, Pausanias, when he goes to Olymp where it's involved with the story of Demeter and
坚守温泉关是希腊人阻止波斯人前进的最佳选择。但他们没有去，因为要举行运动会。这并不是因为他们对体育着迷，尽管他们的确着迷。而是因为奥运会具有不可思议的地位，被视为对神明神圣的事物。所以，同样地，当保萨尼亚斯去奥林匹亚时……那里的故事与德墨忒尔和珀耳塞福涅有关，珀耳塞福涅进入冥界，然后回来待六个月，接着又回去。这基本上都关乎生死。所以它绝对处于凡人可能想要了解的一切事物的核心。但他却说，奥运会，奥林匹克运动会是——奥运会庆典达到了那个水平。事实上，当我用“奥林匹克运动会”作为庆典的同义词时，那是错的，因为运动会只是更广泛庆典的一部分。让我们回到起源。所以它们是什么时候——传统日期是公元前776年，对吧？我们是从亚里士多德那里得知这一点的，我没记错吧？他说那是公元前776年。
Persephone and Persephone going into the underworld and then coming back for six months and going back. And it's all basically about life and death. So it's absolutely at the heart of everything that a mortal might want to learn. But he says that the Olympics, the Olympic Games are, the Festival of the Olympics are on that level. And actually, when I say Olympic Games as a synonym for festival, that's wrong, because the games are only a part of the broader festival. Let's go back to the origins. So when did they, the conventional date is 776, isn't it? And we get that from Aristotle, am I right? That he says it was 776 bc um yes well we we get it also from um a guy called hippias of
嗯，是的，我们也是从一个叫伊利斯的希波阿斯（Hippias of Ellis）那里得知这一点的。伊利斯是一个小镇，在历史的长河中，它逐渐垄断了运动会和庆典，并宣称对它们拥有所有权。基本上，如果你赢得了短跑比赛——这是第一场比赛，据说是由一个叫科罗伊沃斯（Koroibus）的屠夫赢得的，对吧——从那一刻起，你作为赢得短跑比赛的人的名字，就会……你知道的，希腊人就是用这种方式来确定日期的，这就是他们使用的纪年系统。所以这有点像——我的说，这有多精英啊？你赢了一场短跑比赛，然后你的名字，你知道的，将永远被那些编写历史的人所使用。顺便插一句，我们前几天在斯巴达，现代的斯巴达。正如我儿子所说，它不太符合他对古代斯巴达的想象。但在现代斯巴达的中心，有一座纪念碑，一座奥运会纪念碑，上面刻着每一位赢得奥运会冠军的斯巴达人的名字，可以追溯到公元前8世纪左右或诸如此类的时间，一直延续到21世纪初。我想，他们基本上是在假装中间没有任何断代。他们假装奥运会还是原来的那个东西，这就是斯巴达。所以我很喜欢这一点，他们依然在
ellis and ellis is the the kind of the town that um over the course of history comes to kind of monopolize and and lay claim to the games and the festival um and essentially if you win the sprint which is the first race and it's won by this butcher supposedly called koroibus right then nice from that point on your name as the guy who wins the sprint you you know this is how the greeks date this is this is the dating system that they use so it's kind of i mean how elite is that you win a sprint and then your name, you know, is going to be used forever after by people drawing up histories. Well, just to interject on this, we were in Sparta the other day, in modern Sparta, which, as my son said, is not,
缅怀这些家伙，你知道的，在2500年前，他们依然为他们的斯巴达奥运英雄保留着这样一座纪念碑。所以这些名字确实流芳百世了。嗯，是的，绝对是的。因此，希腊的竞争者们也知道这一点——那种名望，从某种意义上说，就是其中的关键。但你不会感到惊讶地知道，这里面有些复杂情况。其中之一就是，你知道，这是真的吗？事实上，主流观点可能认为它大致是真的。什么，那个屠夫确实赢了之类的事情？
it doesn't quite live up to his image of ancient Sparta. But in the middle of modern Sparta, there is a monument, an Olympic monument, and it has the names of every Spartan who won the Olympics, going back to the 8th century BC or whatever it is, and going right up to the early 21st century. And I thought, I mean, they're basically pretending there's no break. They're pretending that the Olympic Games are the same thing and that's Sparta. So I loved that of that they're still
也许吧。谁知道呢？我的意思是，我们真的无从知悉，但它似乎是可行的。不过，这种——你知道的，我们可以承认这是一个历史记载，但对希腊人来说，这——好吧，恐怕我要用那个词了，即运动会的“神圣特质”。是的，我很高兴你这么做了，汤姆。我的意思是，如果你不说，那才叫令人失望呢。我知道这与神话交织在一起。好吧，所以对于希腊人来说，你基本上可以同时在脑海中保留三到四种不同的想法。所以你可以有这样一种观念，即有一个清晰可辨的起跑点，你站上起跑器，你知道的，发令枪响，你出发了，运动会开始了。但与此同时，你还得把它与你脑海中关于神灵和英雄传说的想法交织在一起。正如希腊人一贯的做法那样，并没有什么
remembering these guys you know 2500 years ago and they still got this sort of monument to their to their spartan olympic heroes so the names do live forevermore well yes yes absolutely um and so greek contenders knew that i mean the fame that you, in a sense, the kind of the key to it. But it won't surprise you to know that there are complications. So one of them is, you know, is this true? And actually, the kind of the weight of opinion is probably that it vaguely is. What, that the butcher did win and all that sort of stuff? Yeah, perhaps. Who knows? knows i mean we've got no way really i've known but it seems it seems feasible but this this kind of you know we we
权威的说法。所以比赛在奥林匹亚举行。奥林匹亚，显然，这让人联想到奥林匹斯山，那是众神的住所，众神之王宙斯在那里统治。它被用作——它是以奥林匹斯命名的吗，汤姆？它是以奥林匹斯山这个地方命名的吗？嗯，它是以奥林匹亚的宙斯命名的，所以宙斯主宰着运动会。因此，关于运动会起源的传说之一——同样要追溯到保萨尼亚斯，他确实是这方面的关键来源——他说，有人说宙斯就是在奥林匹亚与克罗诺斯本人摔跤，争夺天国的王座；有人说他在奥林匹亚举行运动会，与克罗诺斯本人争夺天国的王座。有人说他举办运动会是为了庆祝他的胜利。
can recognize that that's a historical account but for the greeks this this well i'm afraid i'm gonna use the word the sacral quality of the game yeah i'm so glad you did that tom i mean it would be disappointing if you didn't i know there's interwoven with myth okay so you can basically with the Greeks you can hold you know kind of three or four ideas simultaneously in your head so you can have this idea that there is a kind of recognizable starting point that you get on the blocks you know firing gun goes and you're off the games have begun but at the same time you also have to kind of enmesh it in your ideas about the stories told of the gods and the heroes. And as is always the way with Greece, there is no
克罗诺斯是宙斯的父亲，他吞下了自己的孩子，因为曾有预言说他会被自己的孩子推翻。因此，他在孩子们出生时就将他们吞食。但他被骗了，因为宙斯的母亲给了他一块用襁褓裹着的石头。于是宙斯得以存活，并前来击败了他。所以这就将奥运会的起源直接钉在了奥林匹斯神族统治的开端、奥林匹斯神族的到来这一时刻。这就是其重要性的衡量标准。但汤姆，我读到了这样一个故事。我今天才刚读到——是的，珀罗普斯，坦塔罗斯的儿子，一个曾被自己的父亲作为食物端上餐桌供诸神食用、却大难不死的人（这不是我们大多数人都能吹嘘的经历），
definitive account. So it's held at Olympia. Olympia, obviously, there's the resonance with Olympus, the home of the gods, where Zeus, the king of the gods, rules. And it's used- Is it named after Olympus, Tom? Is it named after mount olympus the place well it's it's named after olympian zeus so zeus presides over the games and so therefore one of the stories that's told about the origins of the games um and again going back to borsamias who really is that kind of you know the crucial source for this he says some say zeus wrestled there at olympia with kronos himself for the throne of heaven um some say he held the games as a at Olympia with Kronos himself for the throne of heaven. Some say he held the games as a celebration of his triumph.
但他确实经历过并活了下来——他曾与他未来的岳父进行过一场战车比赛，在这场比赛中，他用蜡替换了岳父战车车轮的销子，结果车轮脱落，岳父死了。随后，他举办了葬礼运动会来缅怀他的岳父，这后来就演变成了奥运会。难道这不是运动会的起源吗？这也是另一个故事，是的。而这正是那个实际上最终胜出的故事——我说过你可以把所有这些不同的想法同时装在脑子里。所以，将起源追溯到宙斯是很重要的。但是，是的，绝对没错。
Kronos was Zeus's father who swallowed, there was a prediction that he would be toppled by his child. And so he devours his children as they're born. And he gets tricked because Zeus's mother gives him a stone wrapped in swaddling clothes. And Zeus is then able to live and comes and defeats him. So that is kind of pinning the origins of the Olympics right to the beginning of the reign of the Olympians, the coming of the Olympians. So that's the kind of measure of its significance. But Tom, I read this story. I read it only today that uh pelops yes the son of tantalus a man who had survived being eaten by the gods being served to the gods as food by his own father which is not a claim many of us can make
珀罗普斯，伯罗奔尼撒半岛就是以他的名字命名的，而你现在就坐在那里。是的。事实上，这里面也与厄琉西斯秘仪（Eleusinian Mysteries）有着某种联系，因为唯一吃了一小块珀罗普斯身体的神是德墨忒尔，因为她当时正在为珀耳塞福涅服丧，珀耳塞福涅刚刚被冥界之王哈迪斯劫持。所以从那一刻起，众神将他重新组合，让他复活。从那时起，他有了一个象牙肩膀，用来替换被德墨忒尔咬掉的那一部分。所以他来自安纳托利亚，穿过爱琴海，来到了后来被称为
but he had he had done this and lived to tell the tale that he had a chariot race with his prospective father-in-law in which he replaced the linchpins and the wheels of this father-in-law's uh chariot with wax so that they melted and he died and he then held funeral games to remember his his sort of father-in-law which became the olympics is that not the origin of the games so that's that's another story yeah and that's the one that actually the kind of kind of wins you know i say you can keep all these different ideas in your head. So it matters to identify the origins with Zeus. But yes, absolutely.
伯罗奔尼撒（珀罗普斯之岛）的地方。他去了一个叫比萨（Pisa）的地方——这不是意大利那个地方，它离奥林匹亚将要建起的地方大约有一英里。确实如此，那里有一个叫俄诺玛罗斯（Oenomaus）的家伙，他是那里的国王，有一个女儿叫希波达米亚（Hippodamia）。就像克罗诺斯曾被预言会死于儿子之手一样，俄诺玛罗斯也被预言会死于娶他女儿的男人之手。所以他对此很不高兴，于是他向每一个求婚者发起战车比赛的挑战，条件是如果发起挑战的求婚者输了，就会被处死。因此，珀罗普斯来了，当他们迎他进入比萨、来到他未来岳父的宫殿时，
Pelops, who gives his name to the Peloponnese, where you are sitting now. Yeah. And actually, there's a link to the Lucian mysteries there as well, because the one god who eats a bit of Pelops is Donita, because she's in mourning for Persephone, who's just been abducted by the by Hades the king of the underworld and so from that point on the gods kind of bring him reconstitute him bring him back to life from that point on he has a an ivory shoulder to replace the bit that Demeter had snagged. So he's from Anatolia he crosses Aegean he comes to what will become to be called the
看到的是一种……你知道的，一排头骨，腐烂的脑袋，血肉正在滴落。我们当中有很多人对与自己岳父相处时的这种场景都非常熟悉。所以他显然很紧张，但他有优势，因为他拥有神赐的有翅神马，所以这算是一种优势。但他想要万无一失，于是他贿赂了他未来岳父的御者，一个叫米尔蒂洛斯（Myrtilos）的家伙，正如你所说，把车轴上的辐条——也就是用来固定车轮的东西——换成了蜡。于是岳父死了，珀罗普斯结了婚，成了一位伟大的英雄。
Peloponnese the island of Pelops and um he goes to a place called pisa which isn't the place in italy it's about a mile from where the games the where olympia will be and um absolutely yes so there's a guy called oinomaius who's the king there and he has a daughter hippodamia and a bit like kronos having been told that he will be killed by a son Onomius has been told that he will be killed by the man who marries his daughter and so he's not keen on this and so every suitor he challenges a suitor to a chariot race with the proviso that if the guy who who wins the chariot race loses, he could be killed. And so Pelops arrives and they're welcoming him to Pisa above the palace of his prospective father-in-law,
但他贿赂了米尔蒂洛斯。他曾对他说，你知道的，我会给你各种各样的好东西。于是米尔蒂洛斯来找珀罗普斯索要他的奖赏。你读到珀罗普斯是怎么做的吗？他杀了他吗？他确实这么做了。他把他从悬崖上推了下去。这太残酷了吧？
a kind of, you know, a rack of skulls, decaying heads, the flesh dripping off. A lot of us are very familiar with those kinds of scenes with our own fathers-in-law. Yes. So he obviously is twitchy, but he's got advantages because he's got winged steeds that are a gift from the gods, so that's a kind of advantage, but he wants to make absolutely sure and so he bribes his father, prospective father-in-law's charioteer, a guy called Myrtilos, to exactly, as you say, replace the spokes with the axle, the thing to keep the wheels in, with wax. And so the father dies, Pelops marries, and is a great hero.
这太不讲武德了。确实很残酷。这太不讲武德了。所以珀罗普斯，你知道的，他并不是个好人。不。我现在对身处伯罗奔尼撒半岛感到有点不舒服了。所以珀罗普斯统治了这里。一切都很好。
But he has bribed Mytilus. He said, you know, I'll give you all kinds of goodies. And Mytilus comes to Pelops for his reward. And did you read what Pelops does? Does he kill him? He does. He chucks him over a cliff. That's harsh, isn't it?
但他的家族受到了一种诅咒。我知道你刚去过迈锡尼，对吧？是的，阿特柔斯王室（House of Atreus）。阿特柔斯是珀罗普斯的儿子。所以阿伽门农、克吕泰涅斯特拉、厄勒克特拉，所有这些故事。所有这些都源于那场灾难性的战车比赛。好吧，对珀罗普斯来说不是灾难性的，但对他的后代来说是灾难性的。绝对是的。所以你在那里有一种感觉——因此在体育界，我们谈论英雄。有很多关于英雄的讨论。在希腊，英雄是一个略带威胁性的词。它是指那种带有某种神性的人，
That's bad form. It is harsh. It's very bad form. So Pelops, you know, he's not a nice guy. No. I'm feeling bad about being in the Peloponnese now. So Pelops reigns. It's all great.
而神性总是危险的。所以珀罗普斯并不是一个讨人喜欢的人，我的意思是，他是个骗子，他真的非常不讨人喜欢。然而他身上带有一种阴暗的气质、一种奇异的气质、一种希腊意义上的妖异色彩。这种奇异和诡谲的感觉一直笼罩着随后兴起的运动会。所以你觉得，运动会有一种赎罪的意味吗？这会不会太夸张了？我认为这太夸张了。我认为关键在于，英雄的时代已经过去了。它随着特洛伊战争而结束。但当你来到奥林匹亚，如果你正在观看战车比赛或摔跤或诸如此类的项目，当你看到惊人的表现时，你就会尽可能地接近我们所有人所生活的铁器时代中的英雄时代。
But there is a curse that's been put on his family. And I know you just went to Mycenae, didn't you? Yes, House of Atreus. Atreus is the son of Pelops. So Agamemnon, Clytemnestra, Electra, all that stuff. All that stems from this disastrous chariot race. Well, not disastrous for Pelops, but disastrous for his successors. Exactly, yes. And so you have there the sense that – so in sport we talk about heroes. A lot of talk about heroes. A hero in Greece is something faintly menacing. It's someone who kind of has a touch of the divine,
而这正是它的魅力所在——它仿佛为这种诡异打开了一扇时空之门。所以，你拥有宙斯作为创始人之一，珀罗普斯是另一个，第三个则是赫拉克勒斯（你知道的，他完成了十二项伟业）。另一个传说是，他在完成伟业后来到了这里，创立了运动会，并在珀罗普斯的陵墓前献祭了一只黑公羊。这是他们每四年在运动会期间要做的事情。他们向珀罗普斯献祭一只公羊。你正在参与这些极其生动的故事。它们是活生生的，是你所做事情的一部分。这绝对是古代奥运会一切核心的基础。
and the divine is always dangerous. So pelops is not a pleasant guy i mean he's he's a cheat um he's really not pleasant at all and yet he has something of the night about a strain something of the strange something of the kind of demonic in the greek sense um and that sense of the strange and the weird hangs over the games that then kind of emerge. So there's a sense of the games being expiating sin, do you think? Is that too strong? I think that is too strong. I think the key is that the age of heroes has passed. So it passes with the Trojan War. But you come to Olymplympia and if you're watching the chariot races or the wrestling or whatever and you see astounding performances you are as close to the age of heroes as you possibly can be in the age of iron we all live in and and that's that's the fascination of it that it's kind of opening up a portal
为了暂时跳出神话，运动会的概念是从哪里来的？这是希腊人从其他地方学来的吗？他们是从哪里学来的？从克里特岛、埃及、安纳托利亚，还是他们自己发明的？其他地方也有运动会吗？我认为这是对……一种力求成为最好的执念的表达。所以希腊人可以把任何事情变成一场竞赛。你知道的，你可以把……你可以举办悲剧、喜剧、诗歌竞赛，甚至还有选美比赛、织布比赛。我的意思是，绝对没有任何事情是希腊人不能把它变成一场竞赛的。
to the weird so you've got you've got zeus is one of the founders pelops is the other the third one is heracles you know with his 12 labors and and the other story is that um he comes there after he's finished his labors and he institutes the games and he sacrifices a black ram before the tomb of Pelops. This is something that they do every four years of the games. They sacrifice a ram to Pelops. You are taking part in these incredibly vivid stories. They are alive and a part of what you were doing. That is absolutely fundamental to everything that the Olympics in antiquity are about.
我才不会花钱去看织布比赛呢。但如果你是个希腊人，你可能会。特别是，你知道的，如果是雅典娜对阵阿拉克涅，你知道失败者会被变成蜘蛛。这倒也是。我会去看，我绝对会花钱去看这个。是的，这就是衡量标准。
So just to get away from the myth for a second, where did the idea of games come from? Is it something the Greeks have got from, where have they got it from? From Crete, from Egypt, from Anatolia, or do they invent it? Are there games in other places i think it's an expression of um a kind of obsession with being best so the greeks can make a contest out of anything you know you can make a contest out of well you may famously play so tragedy and comedy poetry but it's kind of beauty contests um weaving i mean there's absolutely nothing that the Greeks can't make into a contest.
每件事都有风险。这在某种程度上反映了希腊人的方式——他们没有为了运动而运动的概念。所以我们之前谈论过登上领奖台、金银铜的概念。但基本上，没有铜牌或银牌。要么你赢，要么你输。当你赢了的时候，你得到的福利之一就是你可以委托创作一首胜利赞歌。所以这就像是，我不知道，请碧昂丝或某人为你在100米赛跑中的胜利庆祝一样，诸如此类。蕾哈娜。
I wouldn't pay to see the weaving contest. But if you're a Greek, you might. And particularly, you know, if it's kind of Athena against Arachne, you know that the loser's going to be turned into a spider. That's true. I would pay to, I'd definitely pay to see that. Yeah, so that's the measure.
而在古希腊做这件事的名人，是一个来自底比斯的叫品达（Pindar）的人。品达是个剧作家吗？不，他写这些颂歌，这些胜利赞歌。这就是他最主要为人所知的地方。因此，在他为胜利者歌功颂德的同时，他也描写了失败者。就在你在希腊沐浴阳光的时候，我昨天经历了一场灾难性的板球比赛，我得了个鸭蛋（零分）出局了。你总是这样，汤姆，不是吗？你总是——不总是，不总是。我投了让我们输掉比赛那一轮球，那真是一场灾难。
There's jeopardy in everything. And it kind of reflects the way in which the Greeks, they have no concept of sport for sport's sake. So we were talking about podiuming, the idea of gold, silver, and bronze. But basically, there is no bronze or silver. You win or you lose um and and when you win you one of the perks you get is you get to commission a kind of victory hymn so it's like you know it's like i don't know getting beyonce or somebody to celebrate your victory in 100 meters something like that rihanna um and the the famous guy who does this uh ancient Greece is a guy called Pindar from Thebes.
我回来后为了准备这期节目读了一些品达的作品，我读到了关于失败者的这段话，品达写道：“当他们回到母亲身边时，没有欢乐的归乡，没有甜蜜的笑声，没有穿过幽暗小巷的狂喜洪流，他们畏缩着溜走，躲避着敌人，再也没有……被失败的意识所折磨……”哦，汤姆，我的心为你的遭遇感到滴血。显然，在这场板球比赛之后，你经历了一个灵魂的黑夜。我是的。我是的。所以，根本没有那种“虽败犹荣的英国选手获得第八名”之类的事。对，没错。任何获得第八名的人，任何获得第二名的人都是失败者。
Is he a playwright, Pindar? No, he writes these odes, these kind of victories. That's what he's chiefly known for. And so as much as he's writing in praise of the winner, he's also writing about the losers um and uh while you were sunning yourself in in um in greece yesterday i had this disastrous game of cricket where i got out for naught um that always happens to you tom isn't it you always go not always not always i'd bowl the over that lost us the game it was absolutely disaster um and i came back and was reading some pinder in preparation for this episode and i came across this about the losers where Pinder writes no
然后你灰溜溜地溜回去。没错。某个步履蹒跚、拖在第五名的勇敢苏格兰长跑运动员，没用。绝对一点用都没有。绝对没用。所以我觉得，那种渴望成为最好的雄心……
joyous homecoming for them on their return to their mothers no sweet laughter no surge of joy down dark alleyways they slink avoiding their enemies nor that by the consciousness of their defeat oh Tom my heart bleeds for you I. You've clearly been through a dark night of the soul after this cricket match. I have. I have. So there's none of this, you know, plucky British contender coming in eighth kind of thing. Right, yeah. Anyone who comes in eighth, anyone who comes in second is a loser.
所以这里没有科林斯精神（Corinthian spirit）。科林斯精神完全是英国人的发明。古希腊根本没有什么科林斯精神。没有。那是一种……所以那种业余精神……希腊人也没有“业余选手”这个词。现代奥运会中的那种倾向是——
And you slink back. Exactly. Some gallant Scottish long-distance runner trailing in in fifth, no good. Absolutely no good at all. Absolutely no good. So I think that it's that kind of ambition to be the best.
好吧，我确信当我们聊到关于现代奥运会的节目时会谈到这一点，但这源于什罗普郡（Shropshire），对吧？这是英国人的发明。什罗普郡和科茨沃尔德（Cotswolds），这两个地方我都非常熟悉，基本上是现代奥运会的摇篮。但我们稍后再谈这一点。汤姆，运动员们——他们没有“业余选手”这个词，但参加比赛的运动员都是业余选手，对吧？
So there's no Corinthian spirit. The Corinthian spirit is a total British invention. There was no such thing as the Corinthian spirit in ancient Greece. No. That's a kind of... So that amateur spirit... The Greeks have no word for amateur either. That strain within the modern Olympics is...
他们肯定不是职业选手吧？嗯，你必须训练10个月。而且在这其中的一个月里，你必须在伊利斯进行训练。虽然你赢得胜利后不会拿到现金奖励，但当你回去后，你会得到各种各样的福利、好东西、赞助协议以及诸如此类的东西。是的，茶叶公司会排队雇用你作为网红，正如播客主持人那样。没错。
Well, I'm sure we'll talk about that when we get onto our programme about the modern Olympics, but it comes from Shropshire, doesn't it? It's a British invention. Shropshire and the Cotswolds, two places I know very well, are basically the cradles of the modern Olympics. But we will come onto that later on. Tom, the athletes, they have no word for amateur, but the athletes that are participating are amateurs, aren't they?
这需要时间和金钱来做到这一点。是的。所以科罗伊沃斯，比如那个屠夫，他很不寻常，因为通常屠夫没有时间花10个月来为短跑进行训练。所以总的来说，参赛者们相当……他们很有钱吗？他们往往非常富有，是的。你知道的，这有点像今天，不是吗？因为往往是富裕国家赢得最多的奖牌。
They're not professionals, surely? Well, you have to train for 10 months. And for one of those months, you have to do it at Ellis. And it's true you don't get paid for your victory. But when you go back, you're guaranteed all kinds of perks and goodies and sponsorship deals and things like that. Yes, tea companies will queue up to employ you as an influencer, as is the case with podcast presenters. Exactly.
当然，人们也经常说有太多公学（注：英国私立精英学校）出身的男孩诸如此类的话。是的，完全如此。所以情况完全一样。然后，当然，还有一个更深层的维度，那就是——在竞技场中，也就是战车比赛和骑马比赛中，拿到奖牌的人并不是那个驾着战车或骑着马的人，
It requires time and money to do that. Yeah. So Karoibos, for instance, the butcher, he's unusual because generally butchers don't have time to have 10 months to train for a sprint. So by and large, are the contestants quite, are they rich? They tend to be very rich, yeah. You know, it's a bit like today, isn't it? Because it tends to be wealthy countries that win the most medals.
而是拥有这些马匹的人。因为马匹要贵重得多。这是我真的很想问你的问题，因为我当时在看著名胜利者的名单，我看到例如托勒密埃及的女王阿西诺伊二世（Arsinoe II）曾赢得过战车比赛。我想，真的吗？我以为女性是不被允许参加奥运会的，但显然她赞助了或者其他什么，
Of course, and people often say too many public school boys and all this kind of thing. Yes, exactly. So it's exactly the same. And then, of course, there's the further dimension, which is that um in the uh the hippodrome so the chariot racing and the um the riding on horseback um the person who gets the medal isn't the person who's driving the chariot or the person who's riding the horse
赞助了某个战车御者。当然，马其顿的腓力二世，据说亚历山大大帝出生那天，他的马赢得了比赛，但他自己并没有亲自去驾车参赛。所以这有点像英国女王的马赢了德比赛（Derby）或者诸如此类的事情。是的，完全正确。是的，我想我们应该休息一下，但先简单谈谈女性的问题。女性是不被允许参赛的，她们甚至不被允许进入圣地。
it's the person who owns the horses so horses are much more valuable this is something i really want to ask you about because i was looking at the list of famous winners, and I saw that, for example, Arsinoe II, Queen of Ptolemaic Egypt, had won the chariot race. And I thought, really? I thought women weren't allowed to participate in the Olympics, but clearly she had sponsored or whatever,
已婚女性更是不准去参加庆典。所以这非常大男子主义。等等。已婚女性不行，但未婚女性可以吗？嗯，某种程度上，是的。所以妓女是被允许去的，高级交际花、未婚的处女。尽管由于这里基本上是一个巨大的狂欢场所，未婚处女……尽管由于这里基本上是一个巨大的狂欢场所，总的来说，未婚处女往往不会去那里。但毫无疑问，作为一个女性，你是绝对不被允许参赛的。你能参赛的唯一方式就是派出战车参赛。所以赢得奥运会比赛的第一个女性是一个斯巴达人——我确信她的名字会出现在那份斯巴达胜利者的名单上——名叫基尼斯卡（Kyniska），她在公元前396年派出了战车参赛，并在四年后的下一届奥运会上再次获胜。她留下了这样一段精彩的碑文，据幸存下来的文字记载：“我的父亲和兄弟们都是斯巴达国王，我在此宣布自己是全希腊唯一赢得桂冠的女性。”所以她被作为奥运会的伟大英雄而被纪念。但还有另一个女性扮演了关键角色，她叫韦罗尼克（Veronique），她属于——她来自一个伟大的拳击世家。她是个拳击手吗？不，她不是。
some other chariot racer. And of course, Philip of Macedon, his horse won on the day, supposedly, when Alexander the Great was born, But he wasn't racing it himself. So it's rather like the Queen's horse winning the Derby or whatever. Yeah, that's exactly right. And yeah, I think we should go to a break, but just quickly on the issue of women. So women are not allowed to compete and they're not even allowed to go into the sanctuary.
但她属于这个家族。她嫁给了一个拳击手。他是一位奥运冠军，他的祖父、父亲、兄弟都是，而且他的儿子也正在接受训练，想要成为奥运冠军。而这个儿子的父亲——所以这个儿子，他叫皮萨多鲁斯（Pisadorus）。
And married women are not allowed to go to the festival full stop. So it's very sexist. Hold on. Married women aren't, but single women are? Well, kind of, yes. So prostitutes are allowed to go, high class courtesans, unmarried virgins. Although since it's a massive kind of whore fest, by and large, unmarried virgins although since it's a massive kind of whore fest by and large unmarried virgins tend not to go there but definitely you know as a woman you're not allowed to compete but the one way that you can compete is to enter chariots and so the very first woman to win in the olympic games is a spartan and I'm sure her name would have been on that list of
他来自罗得岛。他正忙着为奥运会进行训练，而他的父亲去世了。由于父亲一直在训练他，所以他陷入了困境，你知道的，他本该由父亲训练。就在这时，一个神秘的人物出现了，身披一件白色斗篷。他以为这是一个神或者英雄，前来指导他……
Spartan victors, called Kyniska, who enters the chariot in 396, wins again four years later in the next bout of the Games. And she has this kind of wonderful inscription, which the survivor says, my father and brothers were kings of Sparta. I proclaim myself the only woman in all of Greece to have won the crown. So she's commemorated as a kind of great hero of the Olympics. But there's one other woman who plays a key role, which is a woman called Veronique, who has a, she's kind of part of this great boxing tradition. Is she a boxer? No, she's not.
训练一直在进行，你知道的，他们在罗得岛完成了九个月的训练。他们前往奥林匹亚。他们在伊利斯完成了为期一个月的训练。然后是前往奥林匹亚的游行，在村子里安顿下来。比赛的时刻到了。皮萨多鲁斯赢了，
But she belongs to this. She's kind of married to one. He's an Olympic champion. His grandfather, his father was, his brothers were, and his son is training to become one as well. And the son's father, so this son, he's called Pisadorus.
他赢得了决赛。而那个身披斗篷、带着风帽的教练激动得跳过了栅栏。当然，他们——就像苏格兰人一样，他们不穿裤子，不穿内衣，于是所有人都能够看到，这个神秘的人物实际上是一个女性。结果证明她就是韦罗尼克（Ferinike），她的名字非常贴切地意为“胜利的带来者”。这可是死罪。如果你是一个女性，被发现在运动会上，你就会被从山顶上扔下去。
He's from Rhodes. he's in busy training for the for the games and his father dies and his father's been training him so he's stuck you know he's gonna have to train him and then this mysterious figure appears cloaked in a white cloak um and he assumes that it's a god who's or a hero who's come to uh to to coach him um coaching goes through you know they do their nine months training in Rhodes. They go to Olympia. They do their months training in, in Ellis.
所以……所以他们被带到奥运裁判面前，你知道的，裁判们在商议：“我们该怎么办？”他们决定，因为她来自这个伟大的王朝、这个伟大的体育世家，他们绝对不能把她从悬崖上扔下去。所以他们说：“好吧，我们饶了你。你将成为唯一一位训练出奥运冠军的女性。”这就是用特例来证明规则。但他们制定了一条新规则，那就是从这一刻起，不仅是运动员，连教练也必须赤身裸体地进行展示。
And then the procession to, to Olympia, settle down in the village. The time comes for the, for the game. Pisadoris is, is, is he wins,
天哪，太滑稽了。而且，你知道的，谁不想看这个呢？我想，好吧，我的意思是……这会很有趣，教练和运动员都赤身裸体。我的意思是，想象一下……想象一下被晒伤的情形。这倒也是，但我可能不会花钱去看其中某些……我不知道，东欧的重量级选手。
he wins the final bout. And the trainer who's kind of cloaked and hooded is so excited that he leaps over the fence and of course they you know they like scotsman they don't they don't wear pants they don't wear underwear and everyone is able to see that this mysterious figure is in fact a woman and it turns out to be ferinike whose name aptly enough means bringer of victory and this is a capital offense if you are a woman and you're found at the games you get chucked off a mountaintop yeah so so they're brought before the Olympic judges and um you know they're deciding well
各种奇奇怪怪的地方都长满了毛发。是的。好吧，带着这个令人震惊的备注——这档播客从不放过任何刻板印象。没错。我们该休息一下了，对吧？我们应该留下这个画面让你回味。我们该休息一下，然后回来。我想我们应该谈谈政治。
what are we going to do and they decide that because she is from this great dynasty this great sporting dynasty they can't possibly chuck her off a cliff. And so they say, OK, we'll let you off. You will be the one woman who has trained an Olympic champion. Exception that proves the rule. But they institute a new rule, which is that from this point on, not only the the athletes but also the trainers have to perform in the nude oh my word that is hilarious and i you know i mean who wouldn't like to see that i think okay i mean yeah be great fun the trainers and the athletes in the nude yeah i mean imagine
我想我们应该谈谈奥运休战。我想我们应该谈谈著名的奥运选手。我们有成吨的话题要讨论。一会儿见。好的。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
imagine the sunburn. That's true, but I probably wouldn't pay to see some of those kind of, I don't know, Eastern European heavyweights. Hair sprouting in all kinds of peculiar places. Yes. Well, I think on that shocking note. No stereotype goes unused on this podcast. Right. We should take a break, shouldn't we? We should leave you with that image. We should take a break and we'll return. I think we should talk about the politics.
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的圈内八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告的收听体验、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。为了配合东京奥运会的举办，我们正在畅聊古代奥运会。
I think we should talk about the Olympic truce. I think we should talk about famous Olympians. We've got tons to discuss. See you in a minute. Okay. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
所以，汤姆，有一件事绝对让我着迷，我想它也让许多人对古代奥运会着迷，那就是某种政治维度，尤其是奥运休战的概念——它究竟标志着城邦之间敌对状态的停止，还是意味着你只是不能把武器带进奥运会，或者别的什么？所以请准确解释一下这到底是怎么回事。这更像是一种停战协定。所以战争仍在继续，你知道的，这就是为什么奥运会在公元前480年波斯人入侵时照常举行，他们在伯罗奔尼撒战争期间也照常举行，诸如此类。但本质上，这意味着如果你是一个雅典人或斯巴达人，你可以去参加奥运会，你们会相遇，会同场竞技，每个人都会接受你呆在那里的权利。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the ancient Olympics to coincide with the Tokyo Olympics.
这就是那种理想状态。所以它是全希腊的，这就是伟大的理想。我认为，在希腊世界彼此无休止战斗的背景下，这是敌人相聚的唯一机会，并在某种程度上感受到某种程度的亲缘关系。关于亲缘关系的问题真的非常有趣。
So, Tom, something that absolutely fascinates me and I think has fascinated lots of people about the ancient Olympics is this sort of political dimension and particularly the idea of the Olympic truce, that it marks a kind of whether it marks a cessation of hostilities between the city states or whether you just can't take weapons into the olympics or or what so explain exactly what's going on it's more like an armistice so war carries on um the you know that's why the olympics you know they play them in 480 when the persians are invading and they they play them throughout the peloponnesian war and so on. But essentially, it means that if you're an Athenian or you're a Spartan, you can go to the Olympics and you will meet and you will compete and everyone will accept your right to be there.
那么，能否去参加奥运会是成为希腊人的标志吗？所以，小亚细亚、西西里、意大利等地的希腊殖民地——能否去参加奥运会是成为希腊人的标志吗？所以，小亚细亚、西西里和意大利等地的希腊殖民地会派人去参加奥运会吗？他们绝对会，绝对会。是的，绝对会。嗯，你基本上必须是自由出生的希腊人……那你怎么证明呢？你必须说希腊语吗？你必须证明你会说希腊语吗？是的，裁判们会决定你是否有资格参赛。所以，你知道的，你会知道关于马其顿人算不算希腊人存在分歧……是的，呃……但大体上是的，它是为自由出生的希腊人准备的。所以，说希腊语的人——是的，绝对是的。
And that's the kind of ideal. So it's kind of pan-Hellenic and that's the great ideal. And I think in the context of the Greek world where they are endlessly fighting each other, it is the one chance for enemies to meet up and to kind of, to that extent, feel a certain degree of kind of kinship. That question of kinship is really interesting.
一些最伟大的冠军来自西西里等地。所以他们都聚在一起，教练和运动员们会在伊利斯待上一个月在那里练习。然后，我想是在夏至之后的第一个或第二个满月，当那个时刻到来时，你从伊利斯出发，到奥林匹亚大约有35英里，需要走两天。你知道的，沿途布满了各种仪式，奥运会上会有大量的杀猪祭祀。所以这对猪来说是个坏消息……这对猪来说是个可怕的消息，对公牛来说也是个可怕的消息，我们稍后会讲到。你知道的，你经过一个圣泉，杀头猪；你来到某个英雄做过某事的地点，杀头猪。然后你们所有人都抵达了奥运村。
So is the mark of being a Greek whether or not you can go to the Olympics? So do the Greek colonies in Asia Minor, in Sicily, in Italy and so whether or not you can go to the olympics so do the greek colonies in asia minor in sicily and italy and so on do they send people to the olympics they do absolutely absolutely yeah absolutely um yeah you have to be freeborn freeborn greek basically um and how do you prove you have to speak greek do you have to prove you have to speak greek yes and the judges decide whether you can compete or not um so that you know you'll know that there's kind of disagreement about whether the macedonians say a greek yes yeah uh but by and large yes it's it's it's for freeborn greeks um so greek speakers uh yes and absolutely i mean
奥林匹亚并不是一座城市。所以它有点像格拉斯顿伯里音乐节（Glastonbury）。这是一场盛大的庆典，有着绝佳的氛围。他们住在帐篷里，对吧？他们都睡在帐篷里吗？他们都睡在帐篷里，或者根本不睡。你直接睡在露天。
some of the greatest champions come from um from sicily say and so they all meet up um they uh that you know the the trainers and the athletes will have been at ellis for a month practicing there um and then i think it's it's the kind of the first or second full moon after the summer solstice and when that comes you uh you set off from ellis it's a kind of about 35 miles to olympia um takes you two days um you uh you know the route is marked by various rituals so there's an awful lot of of sacrificing pigs at the olympics so there's bad news for it's terrible news for pigs and it's also terrible news for oxen which will come to you in due course you know but you kind of you go past sacred spring you kill a pig you you come to a place where some hero did something you kill a pig And you all arrive at the Olympic Village.
一些最伟大的冠军来自西西里岛，所以他们都会聚在那里。你知道，教练和运动员们会在埃利斯训练一个月，然后我想那是夏至之后的第一个或第二个满月，当那一刻到来时，你从埃利斯出发，到奥林匹克大约有35英里，需要两天时间。你知道，沿途有各种仪式标记路线，奥运会上会有大量的献祭猪，这对猪来说是个坏消息，对猪来说是极其糟糕的消息，对我们稍后会谈到的公牛来说也是极其糟糕的消息。你知道的，你经过神圣的泉水，杀一头猪；你来到某个英雄做过某事的地方，杀一头猪，然后你们都到达了奥林匹克村。
And so Olympia is not a city. So it's kind of like Glastonbury. It's a great festival. It's a great feel. They stay in tents, don't they? Do they all sleep in tents? They all sleep in tents or not at all. You sleep out in the open.
所以奥林匹亚不是一个城市。它有点像格拉斯顿伯里音乐节。这是一个盛大的节日，感觉棒极了。他们住在帐篷里，对吧？他们都睡在帐篷里吗？他们都睡在帐篷里，或者根本不睡。你睡在露天。
It's incredibly hot. It's incredibly dusty. There are no toilet facilities. So it's even worse than Glastonbury. But here a question about the heat so i'm in greece right now it's incredibly hot mid to late 30s they are competing in the heat of summer is that why they're naked or is the nakedness to do with the worship of the human body kind of thing well the story is is that there's there's contender and his his loincloth slips off while he's running uh and it kind of improves his performance and so everyone goes for it i mean that's the story is that there's a contender and his loincloth slips off while he's running.
这里热得难以置信。尘土飞扬。没有任何厕所设施。所以它甚至比格拉斯顿伯里音乐节还要糟糕。不过这里有个关于炎热的问题，因为我现在在希腊，气温高得吓人，在35度到40度之间，他们是在盛夏的高温中比赛，这就是他们赤身裸体的原因吗？还是说赤身裸体跟崇拜人体之类的有关？好吧，流传的版本是这样的，有个参赛者在跑步时，他的腰带滑落了……
And it kind of improves his performance. And so everyone goes for it. I mean, that's the story that gets told. Pausanias is rather cynical about it. It says that this contender says that it slipped off, but actually he'd realized and thrown it aside to get this competitive advantage. I mean, it's very homoerotic. I mean, there's a lot of kind of ogling and eyeing people up. And one of the things that the Olympic Games offer is that we have male and female different contenders. They divide it up between men and boys.
而且这似乎还提升了他的表现。于是大家都效仿起来。我是说，流传的故事就是这样的。保萨尼亚斯对此持相当怀疑的态度。他说，这位参赛者声称腰带是滑落的，但实际上他是意识到了这一点，然后把它扔掉以获得这种竞争优势。我的意思是，这非常具有同性情色意味。我是说，有很多那种眉来眼去、暗送秋波的现象。奥林匹克运动会提供的一个内容是，我们有男选手和女不同的参赛者。他们把参赛者分为成年人和少年组。
So the first round of games is actually the boys. The first day, they run, they wrestle, they box. When you say boys, what, teenagers? Kind of up to the age of 20. But there are no birth certificates, so it's up to the judges. So there's always the risk if you're a boy and you've entered the boxing and the judge says, actually, you're a man, and you're up against some terrifying man mountain.
所以第一轮比赛其实是少年组。第一天，他们赛跑、摔跤、拳击。你说的少年是指什么，十几岁的孩子吗？差不多20岁以下。但当时没有出生证明，所以全凭裁判说了算。因此总是存在这样的风险：如果你是个男孩，报了拳击项目，结果裁判说：“其实你是个成年人了，”然后你就要对上一座可怕的“人形大山”。
I mean, run away. So it's always a kind of risk. So that's what happens on the first day. And also, the boys compete. And also, you swear an oath. You swear an oath before zeus. And you swear it over a dismembered pig. Pigs again. What do the Greeks got against pigs? And if you cheat, so this doesn't happen very often, but it happens occasionally, you will be fined and the fines will go to make a bronze of you. And your shame will then, you know, it'll be put up publicly and it'll be there forevermore. So what's his name? Is it Ben Johnson?
我的天，赶紧逃吧。所以这总是伴随着某种风险。这就是第一天发生的事情。此外，少年们还要进行比赛。而且，你们还要宣誓。你们要在宙斯面前宣誓。而且你们要在一头被宰杀的猪上方宣誓。又是猪。希腊人跟猪有什么仇？如果你作弊——这种情况虽然不常见，但偶尔也会发生——你就会被罚款，罚款将被用来为你铸造一座青铜塑像。然后你的耻辱就会，你知道的，被公之于众，并且永远留在那里。所以他叫什么名字？是本·约翰逊吗？
Ben Johnson. So it's actually Ben Johnson put up wherever it was. That's quite a deterrent actually, isn't it? It is quite a deterrent, isn't it? So there's actually Ben Johnson put up wherever it was. That's quite a deterrent, actually, isn't it? It is quite a deterrent, isn't it? It's a very good deterrent. I think they should introduce that to all tournaments. You get red carded. Yeah.
本·约翰逊。所以其实就是把本·约翰逊的铜像立在某个地方。这实际上是个相当大的威慑，不是吗？确实是个不小的威慑，对吧？所以其实就是把本·约翰逊的铜像立在某个地方。这实际上是个相当大的威慑，不是吗？确实是个不小的威慑，对吧？这是一个非常好的威慑。我觉得他们应该把这引入到所有的锦标赛中。你直接吃红牌。对啊。
But here's a question about people who – so isn't there some suspicion that people change teams? So I was reading about a man called – I've got my piece of paper – Sies at the 99th olympics so first he competed for crete and then he competed for ephesus the next time the ephesians paid him to represent them because he was a he was a star he was an elite athlete um and then the cretans banished him forevermore because they were so cross with him yeah and there's a further risk that you might be banned because your city has committed some offence.
但这里有个关于那些人的问题——难道大家不怀疑有人会叛变换队伍吗？我之前读到一个叫——我找找我的纸条——西斯的家伙，在第99届奥运会上，他先是代表克里特参赛，接着下一次他又代表以弗所参赛，因为以弗所人花钱雇他代表他们参赛，因为他是个明星，是个精英运动员；嗯，然后克里特人就永远地流放了他，因为他们太生他的气了。对啊，还有一个潜在风险，你可能会因为你的城邦犯了某种罪行而被禁赛。
So this happened to Sparta in the last years of the Peloponnesian War. Sparta is the most powerful city in Greece, but the aliens banished them so that they can't take part. And so various Spartan athletes kind of smuggle themselves in as pretend to be Thebans and so on. So it's a bit like South African athletes in the 1980s 1980s like zola bud or something exactly so so there's absolutely so politics is all part of this this kind of great snarl um so um so yeah so in a way the most famous example of that again in in the backdrop to the peloponnesian war this great war between athens and sparta is
伯罗奔尼撒战争的最后几年，斯巴达就遇到了这种情况。斯巴达是希腊最强大的城邦，但埃利斯人流放了他们，导致他们无法参赛。于是，一些斯巴达运动员就乔装打扮，假装成底比斯人等等，偷偷混了进去。这有点像20世纪80年代的南非运动员，像佐拉·巴德之类的人。完全正确。所以，政治完全是这一切、这种巨大纠葛的一部分。嗯，所以，在某种程度上，最著名的例子——同样是在伯罗奔尼撒战争的背景下，雅典和斯巴达之间这场大战的背景下——
alcibiades who is um the kind of the golden boy of Athens, who plays a key role. He actually switches from Athens to Sparta at one point, then switches back to Athens. But at his kind of peak, as he's preparing the Athenian invasion of Sicily, to kind of signal the power of Athens, he goes to Olympia and he enters, I think it's nine chariots in the chariot race and he takes cheating surely he takes the top three spots yeah well i mean it kind of is cheating but you know and and there are lots of people who do think this is too much but equally there are lots of people who are wowed by it and it's remembered and it's something that uh kind of you
就是阿尔西比亚德斯，他可以说是雅典的“金童”，发挥着关键作用。他一度从雅典跳槽到斯巴达，后来又跳回雅典。但在他的巅峰期，当他正准备雅典对西西里的入侵，为了彰显雅典的力量时，他去了奥林匹亚，我记得他派了九辆战车参加战车赛，这绝对是作弊吧？他包揽了前三名。对啊，我的意思是，这确实有点算作弊，但你知道的，而且有很多人觉得这太过分了，但同样也有很多人为之惊叹，这件事被铭记了下来，并且它成了某种……你知道的，流传后世的东西。所以，嗯，战车赛是第一种成人比赛，对吧？这显然是因为这是追溯到珀罗普斯当年的那场赛车，所以这有点……这是一个很大的亮点，对吧？战车赛绝对是个超级大亮点，然后是赛马，同样，珀罗普斯也有这些马。如果你去奥林匹亚，去参观博物馆，珀罗普斯的那些马雕像，可以说是你能见到的最美丽、最震撼的雕塑之一，它们令人叹为观止。它们唤起了人们对运动的力量、诡异、魅力和恐怖感的感知，我觉得这比我能想到的任何其他从古代流传下来的东西都要好。它们具有极其强大的震撼力。
know lives on so um the the chariot the chariot race is the first kind of adult race right and that's obviously because that's going back to the the race that pelops has done so it's kind of and that's a big highlight isn't it the cherry absolutely massive highlight and then you have the horse race um and again pelops has these horses uh and if you go to if you go to olympia you go to the museum they the horses of pelops are kind of i mean some of the most beautiful terrifying sculptures you could ever see they're breathtakingly and they kind of evoke the the power and the strangeness and the glamour and the terror of the games i think better than almost anything else that i can think of that
嗯，而且我觉得希腊人也有同感。所以特别是战车赛，它们太危险了。当时的情况是，当你在转弯时，始终存在的风险就是你的战车会撞得粉碎，然后你就会丧命。据说在那个转弯处有一个幽灵在游荡。而且没人十分确定他是谁，也许是俄诺玛奥斯，或者是米耳提洛斯，或者神话中的这些家伙之一。但这种认为存在某种诅咒、有幽灵在游荡的想法，我的意思是，这给比赛增添了一种惊险刺激感。好吧，是的。所以你在第二天的早晨进行马术比赛，
survived from antiquity they're incredibly powerful um yeah and and i think the greeks felt that as well so there was particularly with the chariots they were so dangerous there was there was that you know when you turn the risk is always that you're going to kind of your chariot's going to splinter and then you're going to die and it said that there was a ghost that haunted that turning point um and nobody was quite sure who it was but maybe it was oinomaus or myrtilos or you know one of these guys in the myth but but this idea that there is a kind of curse a ghost haunting it I mean it's kind of adds jeopardy to it okay yeah so you have the equestrian events in the morning of the
然后是铁人五项，这同样可以说是希腊人理想的完美体现，也就是你在所有这些不同的技能上都很精通。因为如果你是个跑步运动员，你希望自己身材纤细。如果你参与那些更需要体力的项目，那你就会希望自己体格魁梧。但铁人五项全能运动员可以说是介于两者之间，是体格的完美化身。没错，就是戴利·汤普森。
day to then you have the pentathlon which again it's kind of it is absolutely the kind of the Greek ideal really that you you're proficient at all these various skills. Because if you're a runner, you want to be slim. If you're taking part in the brawnier feats, then you want to be bulky. But the pantathlete is kind of the midpoint, the ideal of physicality. Yeah, the Daley Thompson.
是的，完全正确。然后第二天接近尾声时，会有一场疯狂的大狂欢。这就是阿尔西比亚德斯从雅典带来了各种黄金饰品，并把它们伪装成是自己所有的那一幕。素食主义者也得到了照顾，所以，恩培多克勒作为一名素食者，他去了奥运会，他提供了一头巨大的公牛，这头公牛是用面团做成的烤炉烤出来的，并配有香草、香料等调味品。这太令人印象深刻了。是的，所以知道这一点挺好的，对吧？然后显然所有人都酩酊大醉。
Yes, absolutely. And then day two comes to an ending you have a massive piss up and that's where so alcibiades has brought all the kind of the gold um fittings from athens and he passes it off as his own um and vegetarians are catered for so uh yeah so empedocles who's who's a vegetarian he goes to the olympics and he he um uh he provides this kind of massive ox that's been baked in an oven made of dough and garnished with herbs and spices and things. That's very impressive. Yeah, so that's nice to know, isn't it? And then obviously everyone is absolutely slaughtered.
所以他们醒来时。天气热得要命。你根本不可能参赛。对啊，你能想象吗？我是宿醉得厉害，顶着暴晒，睡在帐篷里。所以你知道，如果你醒来时天气热得要命，而且宿醉头痛欲裂，你需要看什么？我个人会去游泳。他们做了什么？他们为了荣誉宰杀了一头公牛献给宙斯。噢，相比之下，我可真是个弱不禁风的小卡拉米。而且这可以说是……我们知道这很恶心，因为——
So they wake up. It's boiling hot. You can't possibly compete. Yeah, can you imagine? I mean, they're sleeping in the tents with these colossal hangovers the sun pounding down and so you know what you do need to see if you got if you wake up it's incredibly hot and you've got a pounding hangover i'd go swimming personally what do they do they slaughter 100 oxen in honor of zeus oh i'm a bit of a lightweight by comparison and it's it's kind of, we know it's disgusting because –
想想那些苍蝇、血腥味和所有这些。好吧。所以你要向驱蝇宙斯献祭，这意味着驱赶苍蝇的宙斯。哦，真的吗？我不相信这个。我对这到底有没有用持怀疑态度。但显然确实管用。所以据说在祭坛周围，竟然没有苍蝇。你当然可以对这到底有没有用表示怀疑。但显然确实管用。
Just think of the flies and the stench of blood and all that. Okay. So you make sacrifice to Zeus apomweos, which means Zeus who keeps flies away. Oh, right. I don't believe that. I'm sceptical about whether that would work. Apparently it did. So around the altar, apparently there were no flies. You may well express sceptical about whether that would work. Apparently it did.
所以据说在祭坛周围，竟然没有苍蝇。你当然可以表示怀疑。但那个祭坛，你知道是用什么做的吗？死猪？它是用被宰杀的公牛的骨灰与水混合调成糊状制成的。所以它是一大团……这听起来简直是能想象到的最糟糕的场合了。好吧，每个人都说这是一个糟糕的场合。
So around the altar, apparently there were no flies. You may well express scepticism. But the altar, do you know what the altar was made of? Dead pigs? It's made of the ashes of the slaughtered oxen mixed with water into a paste. So it's a great lump of... This just sounds the most terrible occasion imaginable. Well, everyone says it's a terrible occasion,
人太多，苍蝇太多，太热了，太恶心了，但每个人都说这太棒了。所以这就是为什么它能持续一周，因为大家都这么说。这有点……但是是的，这个祭坛是由死公牛的骨灰制成的各种东西。如果你对我说，这难道不是那种我能想象埃隆·马斯克会做的事吗？他们不会的，他们都会赤身裸体。他们要在盛夏的酷热中赤身裸体，四处奔跑。
too many crowds, too many flies, it's too hot, it's too disgusting, but everyone says it's amazing. So that's what makes it last a week, because that's what people say. It's kind of... But yes, this altar is used sorts of uses made up of the ashes of dead oxen if you said to me is it not the kind of thing i can imagine somebody like elon musk doing they're not they're all gonna be naked they're gonna be naked and pounding midsummer
到处都是苍蝇，还有死牛，对吧，太棒了。我明白了，所以你看，这真的和那种现代的、企业间的社交派对大相径庭。我没看到国际奥委会引入其中一些……引入这些真正的传统。所以，这就是你在宙斯神庙里做的事情，你知道的，那里有菲迪亚斯创作的伟大雕塑，他也创作了……帕台农神庙。然后是第四天，这就是跑步比赛。所以你有中长跑，有短跑，有长跑。然后在下午，有真正能讨好观众的项目，那就是摔跤和拳击。
heat there's gonna be like flies everywhere dead oxen yeah it's great i see so you see it's nothing really like the corporate the corporate schmooze fest that is the model i don't see the ioc introduce some of these uh some of these proper traditions so that's so you do and you do that at the temple of zeus you know with its great statue by phidias who also does the uh the the parthenon um And then you have day four, and this is the running. So you've got the middle distance run, you've got the sprint, you've got the long sprint. And then in the afternoon, you've got the real crowd pleasers, which is the wrestling and the boxing.
事实上，你刚才问到会不会被太阳晒伤。所以摔跤手们，我的意思是，他们会在身上抹油，然后涂满尘土。他们肯定在烈日下被烤焦了吧。所以摔跤手们，我的意思是，他们会在身上抹油，然后涂满尘土。他们肯定在烈日下被烤焦了吧，不是吗？我是说，尘土能保护你吗？我是说，那些油。对，我想是的。对，我想是的。
And actually, you asked about getting burnt in the sun. So the wrestlers, I mean, they oil themselves, and then they cover themselves in dust. They're frying, surely, in the sun. So the wrestlers, I mean, they oil themselves and then they cover themselves in dust. They're frying, surely, in the sun, aren't they? I mean, does the dust protect you? I mean, all the oil. Yeah, I guess so. Yeah, I guess so.
但是，我的意思是，你看起来会很奇怪。你看起来就像，那个在《现代启示录》里的谁，从泥浆里爬出来的那个人。哦，马丁·辛。马丁·辛，我的意思是，有点吓人。但他拍那部戏的时候心脏病发作了。你可不想在奥运会上发生这种事。给你。
But, I mean, you can look very odd. You look like, what's his name in Poclips now, kind of rising up out of the mud. Oh, Martin Sheen. Martin Sheen, I mean, kind of terrifying. But he had a heart attack while he was filming that. I mean, you wouldn't want that to out of the mud. Oh, Martin Sheen. Martin Sheen, I mean, kind of terrifying. But he had a heart attack while he was filming that. I mean, you wouldn't want that to happen at the Olympics. There you go.
给你。还有拳击和古希腊混合格斗。是的。这显然是我们现在没有的项目。拳击，这些项目具有可怕的暴力性。我读到过，有人在死后还赢得了古希腊混合格斗的比赛。他叫什么名字？他叫阿里基翁，来自阿卡迪亚。他当时正在锁喉对手，或者正被对手锁喉，然后他折断了对手的……是的，他当时正被用剪刀腿死死缠住。但在被锁喉的同时，他折断了对手的脚趾还是什么的。他的对手说：“我认输。我认输，或随便什么。”就在那个时候，他死了。大家都欢呼说：“我认输。我认输，或随便什么。”就在那个时候，他死了。
There you go. And the boxing and the Pankration. Yes. Which is obviously an event that we don't have. The boxing, these are terrifyingly violent. So somebody won the Pankration when they were dead, I read. What's his name? His name is Arikion. Arikion from
然后大家都欢呼说：“太好了，阿里基翁赢了。”他死了这个事实……对啊。对啊。我的意思是，你真的没有把这推销出去……太棒了。太棒了。在很多方面，古希腊混合格斗甚至更吓人，
Arcadia. He was choking his opponent or being choked and he broke his opponent's... Yeah, he was getting throttled in a scissor grip. But while being throttled, he broke his opponent's toe or something. His opponent said, I yield. I yield or whatever. And at that point he died. And everyone said, hur yield. I yield or whatever. At that point, he died.
因为在这个项目里，你几乎可以做任何事，除了挖掉对手的眼睛或咬他。所以迈克·泰森会被取消资格，但除了这些，你可以抓住他的睾丸。这就是我要说的。绝对的，你可以做所有这些，但不能咬人。是的，我觉得他们的优先级搞错了。难道这不是一个绝佳的奇观吗？我的意思是，你自己并没有赤身裸体。作为观众，你并没有赤身裸体，对吧？没有。你宿醉未醒，还晒伤了。我在为电视转播考虑。
And everyone said, hurrah, Rikian has won. The fact that he's dead is... Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you're really not selling... Great stuff. Great stuff. And in many ways, the Pankration is even more terrifying
身上爬满了苍蝇，但你不是赤身裸体。你在看着男人们互相扭转对方的睾丸。好吧，希望你在看。我的意思是，观众人山人海。体育场太小了，根本应付不过来。所以你得站在其他人身后，看着男人们扭转对方的睾丸。你必须很早就去占个好位置，然后当然，你还要面临一个问题：
because on that, you can literally do anything except gouge out your opponent's eye or bite bite him so mike tyson would be disqualified but anything you can grab his testicles that's what i was going to say absolutely you could do all that but not biting yeah i think they've got their priorities wrong i think wouldn't that be great spectacle i mean you're not naked yourself you're not naked yourself as a spectator, are you? No. You're hungover and sunburned. I'm thinking for TV.
如果你想小便该怎么办？你到得很早，顶着太阳，你只能尿在自己身上。然后最后一个项目是穿着盔甲跑步。所以你要穿上盔甲奔跑。这太荒谬了，因为在希腊38摄氏度左右的天气里，这根本不合逻辑。但这就是斯巴达人发挥他们优势的地方，
Covered in flies, but you're not naked. And you're watching men twisting each other's testicles. Well, hopefully you're watching. I mean, the crowds are massive. The stadiums are too small to cope. So you're standing behind other people watching men twisting their testicles you have to get there very early to get vantage point and then of course you've got the question of
对吧？他们经常赢得这个项目的比赛，对吧？是的，我想是的。对，我想是的。然后，大家都散了，就结束了。第五天，获胜者们会来到宙斯雕像前，被授予他们的橄榄枝桂冠。所以，汤姆，这听起来太糟糕了，你彻底粉碎了我对古代奥运会的所有浪漫幻想。所以，在我们聊到一些伟大的奥运选手之前，我有一个简短的问题：奥运会在希腊被并入罗马帝国之后仍在继续，但非希腊人也开始参与其中，对吧？罗马皇帝和其他罗马人。那么，这是普遍现象，还是只有大人物、那些VIP才这样？基本上只有尼禄。
what do you do if you need a pee you get there really early, the sun you just wet yourself and then the final event is you running in armour so you dress up in armour and run well that's ludicrous because of course in the greek weather 38 degrees centigrade or whatever but that's where the spartans come into their own
但提比略不是也参加了吗？是的，他参加了马术比赛。但总的来说，它仍然以希腊为中心。所以它在罗马帝国早期开始走向衰落。苏拉，也就是那个可怕的将军，他在公元前1世纪初进军罗马并进行了一番……掠夺了奥林匹亚，并用它来资助他在内战中的军队。不过后来奥古斯都对它非常热衷。朱莉娅·克罗娜也对它非常热衷。
right that's so they they often win that do they yeah i guess so yeah i guess so um and then uh everyone goes that's it and the winners on the fifth day they all go to statue of zeus and they're given their um their olive crowns so yeah tom that sounds awful and you have comprehensively shattered any romantic um faith i had in the ancient olympics so one quick question before we get on to some great olympians um it continues after greece has been absorbed into the roman empire but non-greeks are taking part that's right right, isn't it? So Roman emperors and other Romans. Now, is that general or is it just big names, kind of VIPs? It's basically Nero.
尼禄对它极其热衷。哈德良对一切希腊事物都极其痴迷，他也非常热衷于此。它在整个公元2世纪都非常成功。到了公元3世纪，罗马帝国陷入内战，蛮族横扫而过，奥运会开始走向衰落。基本上到了公元4世纪，它已经奄奄一息了。
But didn't Tiberius take part? Yes, he takes part in the Questrian event. But by and large, it remains focused on Greece. So it goes into decline in the early Roman period uh Sulla who's the uh this kind of terrifying general who marches on Rome and and kind of um at the beginning of the first century BC um and he is he plunders Olympia uh and uses it to kind of fund his fund his army in a civil war yeah but then Augustus is very keen on it. Julia Cronin is very keen on it.
然后它……我想有记录的最后一次提及奥运会大概是在公元394年左右吧，狄奥多西大帝，对吧？狄奥多西不是基本上把它取缔了吗？我不确定他是不是把它取缔了。我觉得，我的意思是，基本上是因为没有市场了，因为所有人都成了基督徒，所以没有人再去参加了。所以这某种程度上印证了它具有宗教色彩而非纯粹体育色彩的观点，或者说它的体育本质本身就是宗教性的。他们把它视为一个异教节日，你知道的，那些苍蝇和裸体并不足以弥补异教宗教色彩带来的负面影响。保罗，你知道的，当他写信给哥林多人时，提到了伊斯米亚竞技会。所以他说，你知道的，作为基督徒，我们在为更高的桂冠而竞争。对的，是的。所以他在新约中对奥运会的贬低是显而易见的。我的意思是，基本上是的，如果你不崇拜宙斯，那么……还有什么意义呢？而且宙斯的巨型雕像也被运到了君士坦丁堡，你知道的，被带到那里不是作为一种宗教偶像，而是一种文化象征。所以根本没有需求了。因此，跟我讲讲一些奥运……你有没有准备一些优秀的奥运选手或者一些奥运趣事来分享？
Nero is massively keen on it. Hadrian, who is hugely into everything Greek, he's very keen on it. And it's very successful through the second century. Third century, you get these Rome Empire kind of implodes into civil war, barbarians sweep across, goes into decline. And basically by the fourth century's it's on its last legs
有的，那些往往能流传后世的往往是拳击手和摔跤手，我想是因为他们唤起了赫拉克勒斯精神。所以实际上，有一个人据说是赫拉克勒斯的儿子，一个名叫塞阿根尼斯的人，来自爱琴海北部的萨索斯岛。他在上周播出的关于雕像的节目背景下显得很有趣。是的。因为当他还是个小男孩的时候，他非常热衷于把雕像抱起来到处走，仅仅因为他力气太大。他大概七岁时，就会抱起一座雕像，然后挨训并不得不把它放回原处。
and it it kind of i think the last the last recorded mention of the games is i think three nine four something like that yeah um theodosius the great isn't it it doesn't theodosius ban it basically i'm not sure he bans it i i think it i mean that's that's i think i think basically there's no market for it because everybody has become christian so nobody's going for yeah so that that sort of reinforces that point about it being religious rather than sporting or sporting being religious that they see it as a pagan festival you know the the flies and the the nudity aren't enough to to compensate for the pagan religious connotations. Well, Paul, you know, when he writes to the Corinthians, makes reference to the
当他去世时，他成了一个伟大的英雄，人们为他制作了一座雕像，并把它竖立在萨索斯岛的集市上。这让另一个去参加奥运会却失败了的萨索斯人感到非常糟糕。于是这家伙就跑到雕像前撒尿、乱涂乱画，并对它各种侮辱。雕像对此非常生气，并警告这个家伙说：“小心点。”而这家伙却变本加厉，一错再错。
Ismian games. So he says that, you know, as Christians, we are competing for a higher crown. Right. Yeah. So his dissing of the games is there in the new testament um i mean basically yes if you're not worshipping zeus then um what's the point and the great statue of zeus has been carted off to constantinople um you know it's been taken there not as not as a kind of religious icon but as a kind of you know cultural symbol um so there's just no there's just no call for them and so um tell me about some olymp you've got some have you got some good olympians up your sleeve or some olympic facts or something to yeah so the the ones the ones who um who tend to live on are boxers and wrestlers i think because they
于是最终雕像轰然倒塌，将他压死。哇，这简直是为今天的“推倒雕像”现象提供了一个预兆。是的，我的意思是，这其中带有警示意味。那个被压死的人的儿子们对此感到非常愤怒，于是他们绑架了雕像并把它扔进了海里。然后萨索斯的一切都开始走下坡路。简直糟透了。一切都乱了套。
kind of evoke uh spirit of Heracles. So there's actually, there's one who is said to be the son of Heracles, a guy called Theagones who comes from the island of Thassos in the north of the Aegean. And he's interesting in the context of the episodes that went out last week about statues. Yeah. Because as a young boy, he was very keen on he'd pick
于是他们派使者去德尔斐。德尔斐说：“你们让伟大的塞阿根尼斯被遗忘了。你们取消了塞阿根尼斯的荣誉。”哇，汤姆，我要是早知道这个就好了，在我们进行雕像漫步之前。这太棒了。所以他们不得不“恢复”他的荣誉。这有点像把科尔斯顿的雕像从港口里捞出来。他们必须去他被扔掉的地方，把他打捞上来，重新安放在他的基座上。这就需要给所有这些威廉·格莱斯顿学生宿舍重新命名了。完全是这样。所以，他很有名，但我认为伟大的英雄、真正出名的是一个叫米洛的家伙，他来自西西里的克罗托内，也就是你刚才提到的那些殖民地之一。他是一名摔跤手。他连续五次夺冠。你知道的，这简直是闻所未闻。
up statues and carry them around just because he was so strong he was kind of seven he just pick up a statue get told off and have to take it back um and when he when he died he's a kind of great hero and they make a statue of him put it up in the um in the uh the marketplace in Thassos. And this is awful for another Thassian who had gone to the Olympics and had failed. And so this guy goes and kind of pisses and writes graffiti on the statue and generally insults it. And the statue gets really cross about this and kind of warns this guy off, says, you know, watch it. And this guy carries on, carries on.
他力大无穷，可以把一根绳子绑在头上，然后只要一运劲儿，就能把绳子崩断。我觉得我也能做到。这就是他的拿手好戏。我觉得我也能做到。我的意思是，我不会当着历史回响听众的面直播做这个，但我今晚晚些时候会试试。你现在就可以做。
So eventually the statue keels over and crushes him to death. Wow. That's an omen for and crushes him to death. Wow. That's an omen for today's statue of Obes. Yes, I mean, there's warning there. And the sons of the guy who's been crushed to death are so cross about this that they abduct the statue and dump it in the sea. And then everything goes wrong for Thassos. Just terrible. Everything goes wrong.
如果你想现在做的话，我可以描述一下。我手头没有绳子。噢，太遗憾了。太遗憾了。而且，他还拥有英雄般的饮食。所以你知道他的精英运动饮食吗？可能是猪肉吧，根据这个播客的内容来看。好吧，每天20磅肉。
So they send an emissary to Delphi. And Delphi says, you have great the agonies unremembered. You have cancelled the agonies. Wow. I wish I'd known this before we did our statue walk, Tom. This is great stuff. So they have to uncancel him. So a bit like getting Colston out of the bay. They have to go to where he's been dumped and dredge him up and put him back up on his up on his pedestal so to rename all these william gladstone halls of residence that have been exactly yes so so there's a there's a kind of um he's famous but i think that the great hero the really famous one is a guy called milo who comes from croton which is in sicily so one of those colonies that you were talking about. He's a wrestler. He wins five in a row. You know, I mean, that's kind of unheard of.
20磅？每天20磅面包。两加仑葡萄酒。哇。但他有着非常具有娱乐性的运动式死法。所以有一次他出门，看到一根为了晾干而劈开的树干，中间有用木楔撑开的两半。他觉得好玩，就把木楔拔出来，把手伸了进去。结果两半树干猛地合拢夹住了他，
And he is, he's so strong that he can tie a cord around his head and then just kind of flex and it just bursts the cord. I reckon I can do that. So that's his party trick. I reckon I can do that. I mean, I'm not going to do it live for the rest of history listeners to watch, but I'm going to try later tonight. You can do it now.
他的手拔不出来了。好吧，所以他被这棵树给卡住了，然后被一群狼给吃掉了。哇，这可真不是个好死法，对吧？没有。所以他所有的力量都没能帮到他。根本没用。力量没能拯救他。所以这种可怕的死法是这些奥运人物展现英雄主义的另一种方式。你知道，他们是希腊意义上的英雄，而不是那种，你知道的，拉什福德意义上的英雄。所以还有另一个叫波利达马斯的家伙，他是古希腊混合格斗的大赢家，能赤手空拳杀死狮子，还会捕捉公牛并扯下它们的蹄子。这简直是胡闹。而且他有一次和一些朋友在一个山洞里，发生了地震，他一个人把山洞顶住，让其他人逃了出去，而他自己则被压死了。这才是真正的英雄，对吧？是的，这确实挺英雄主义的。但最阴暗的一个、一个被德尔斐神谕册封为真正英雄的家伙，是一个叫克利奥梅德斯的家伙。同样，他也是那种在比赛中杀死对手的家伙。
I could describe it if you want to do it now. I have no cord to hand. Oh, what a shame. What a shame. But also, he had a diet for heroes. So do you know his elite sports diet? Probably pork, judging by the content of this podcast. Well, 20 pounds of meat a day.
裁判因此取消了他的资格，因为杀死对手被认为太过分了。是的。他因为被取消资格而发疯了，回到了他的家乡岛屿。你知道他在那里做了什么吗？我不知道。他推倒了一所学校，里面有60个男孩，他们全部遇难了。天哪。所以家长们自然对这感到非常愤怒。
20 pounds? 20 pounds of bread a day. Two gallons of wine. Wow. But he had a very entertaining sports death. So he was out and he saw a kind of tree that had been split to dry it out and there were kind of pegs holding the two halves apart and he thought just funny take the pegs out and put his hand in and he put he put his hand in and the two halves of the tree kind of slapped around it and
他们在街上追赶他。因为他是奥运冠军，他能跑得极快。所以他逃到了一座雅典娜神庙里，把自己锁在神庙里。大家都在疯狂地砸门。他躲进了一个箱子里。
he couldn't pull his hand out okay so he was stuck with this tree and he got eaten by a pack of wolves wow that is that's no way to go is it no so all his strength availed him naught it could availed him naught it availed him and so and so it kind of horrible deaths is is another way in which these olympic figures are kind of heroic you know they are heroes in the Greek sense rather than in the kind of, you know, Marcus Rashford sense. So there is there's another one, Polydamus, who was a great kind of winner in the Pankration, who killed lions with his bare hands, who he would capture bulls and pull off their hooves. That's just bad behavior and um and he um they he was with some friends in a cave there was an earthquake uh he held the cave up while they all got out and they got crushed to death so that's him that's a proper hero isn't it yeah that is that's actually quite heroic but the most the most sinister one and the one who is literally proclaimed a hero by the delphic oracle um is a guy called cleomedes and again he's another he's another of these guy who kills his opponent in the in the games
他们破门而入。砸开了箱子。结果他凭空消失了。他不见了。他真的不见了。是的，这可真是一门绝技。所以他们显然派了一个信使去德尔斐，想弄清楚到底发生了什么。德尔斐神谕说：“他是最后的英雄，向他献祭吧，他已不再是凡人。”我认为这在某种程度上是关于他的典范叙述——他就是标准的奥林匹克英雄，因为他真的成了一个神。
and he gets disqualified by this for the judges because killing your opponent is seen as being too much yeah um he he goes mad with this disqualification he goes back to um uh his home island and do you know what he does there um he i don't he pulls down a school and there are 60 boys in it and they all get killed oh my god and so the parents are understandably cross about this. And they chase him through the streets. Because he's Olympian, he can run very fast. So he gets up to a temple of Athena, locks himself in the temple. And they're all banging away. And he hides in a chest.
其中包含着一种令人难以置信的黑暗元素，我认为这是这些奥运会永恒的一部分。这是一个非同寻常的故事，因为它太可怕了。这真是一个可怕的故事。所以他杀死学校里所有这些孩子的行为根本没有受到任何惩罚？这只是被视为对你的……一种完全合理的反应吗？不，这不被认为是合理的，这被认为是可怕的。但比如赫拉克勒斯，他杀了自己的孩子，他被神明逼疯了。那种拥有非凡力量的人往往会发疯并做出可怕事情的观念，正是奥林匹克运动会的内核所在。而被人们铭记的人，往往是因为他们做出了骇人听闻的暴力壮举。这很有趣，不是吗？因为我们对希腊人和奥运会的印象——当然是我们对古代奥运会的印象，我们对古希腊的印象——是那种原始的、纯洁的大理石雕像般的英雄体育精神，这种英雄主义是现代意义上的，几乎是一种失落的黄金时代，充满了牛奶和蜜糖之类的一切。显然，希腊世界要黑暗、阴险得多，远超我们的常识。当我们把它当作一根棍子来批判我们自己、批判现代奥运会时，认为现代奥运会商业化、俗气、被出卖等等，我的意思是，在某些方面，现代奥运会要可爱得多、也更……好吧，它们更无菌。是的，我觉得是这样。但它们缺乏……它们缺乏灵魂，我想这就是我想说的。是的，我觉得古代奥运会是黑暗而可怕的，这就是为什么它们能持续那么久。我的意思是，它们持续了一千多年。比现代奥运会久远得多，当然。长得不可思议。它们之所以能做到这一点，是因为它们在向某种非常真实的希腊人性映照一面镜子——一个对我们现代人来说似乎很熟悉、实则不然的世界。
And they burst in. And they smash open the chest. And he's vanished. He's gone. He has. Yeah, that's quite a party trick so they they they obviously they send a messenger to delphi to try and find out what's what's happened um and the delphic oracle says he is the last hero offer him sacrifice he is no longer mortal and i think that that that in a way is the kind of paradigmatic account of – he's the paradigmatic Olympic hero because he literally becomes a god.
所以民主就是另一个例子。你知道的，雅典人对民主的理解与我们有着天壤之别。我们用同一个词来指代雅典人的系统和我们拥有的系统，这种现象掩盖了它们之间巨大的差异。奥林匹克运动会也完全如此。所以，复兴奥运会的计划简直是一个白日梦，他们永远不可能做到这一点。所以这是一个迷人的窥探，让我们得以一窥一个实际上比我预期的要黑暗得多、坦率说也更让人望而生畏的世界。所以我想，既然我们已经深入了解了古代奥运会的肮脏内幕，我们在下一个播客中也应该对现代奥运会如法炮制，我们应该聊聊诸如慕尼黑奥运会、
And there's that incredible element of darkness to it that I think is a constant part of these games. That's an extraordinary story because it's such a terrible story. It is a terrible story. So he's in no way punished for his killing of all these kids in this school. That's just seen as an absolutely reasonable way of reacting to your – as no it's not seen as reasonable it's seen as terrible but heracles for instance i mean he kills his own children he's driven mad by the gods and that sense that that men of phenomenal strength are prone to go mad and do terrible things that's part of what the olympic
蒙特利尔的灾难、莫斯科和洛杉矶等等。当然还有奥运会的起源。希特勒的奥运会。完全正确。我们将讨论所有这些。所以到时候会有海量的话题可以聊。而且不会那么具有神圣祭祀色彩。苍蝇也会少一些。
games are all about and the people who are remembered are often remembered for feats of kind of hideous violence it's interesting isn't it because our image of the greeks and the olympics certainly our image of the ancient olympics our image of ancient greece is this sort of pristine marble heroic sporting spirit heroic using in the sort of modern sense this sort of almost this lost golden age of you know milk and honey or whatever. And clearly the whole, the Greek world is so much darker and more sinister than we commonly think. And when we use it as a stick to beat ourselves and to beat the modern Olympics,
苍蝇会少一些，而且不具有神圣色彩。所以你是安全的。太棒了。好的，我想我们下次再见啦，汤姆。再见，保重。如果我还……是的，我们下次见。
commercialized and tawdry and sold out and all the rest of it, I mean, in some ways the modern Olympics are much more cuddly and sort of… Well, they're more antiseptic yeah i think and that but they they lack that they lack soul i guess is what i would say yes i think the the ancient games are are dark and terrible and that's why they last as long as they do i mean they you, they last over a thousand years. Far longer, yeah, of course. Inmeasurably longer than the modern Olympics. And they do that because they're holding a mirror up to something very, Greece that seems to us modern, that seems familiar, it isn't.
好的。再见，多米尼克。回见。一路顺风。希望你不会在希思罗机场被隔离在酒店里呆上10天。谢谢你。我觉得与其说这是个祝愿，不如说更像是个威胁。你这是要直接去跟边境部队告状啊。
So democracy would be another example. You know, the Athenian understanding of democracy is immeasurably alien to us. And the fact that we have the same, you know, the same word can apply to the system that the Athenians had in the system that we have disguises the way that it's it's measurably different and the same is absolutely true of the olympics so the so the the project of revitalizing the olympics was an absolute pipe dream they were never going to manage to do that so that's been a fascinating um glimpse into actually a much darker world and frankly more off-putting world than i anticipated. So I think now that we've, you know, got into the sordid underbelly of the ancient Olympics, we should do the same with the modern Olympics in our next podcast and we should do things like, you know, the Munich Olympics,
再见，先生。好的。好的。大家拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》，获取独家番外节目、抢先收听以及无广告体验。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
the disaster in Montreal, Moscow and LA and so on. The origins of the Olympics, of course. Hitler's Olympics. Exactly. We're going to do all that. So there'll be tons to discuss then. And it won't be quite so sacral. And fewer flies.
蒙特利尔、莫斯科和洛杉矶等地的灾难。当然，还有奥运会的起源。希特勒的奥运会。没错。我们打算把这些都讲一遍。所以到时候会有大量的话题可以讨论。而且它不会那么神圣，苍蝇也会少一些。
There'll be fewer flies and it won't be sacral. So you'll be safe. Yes. Great. So we will see you all next time, I guess. Tom. See you soon. If I do still. Yes, us.
苍蝇会少一些，而且也不那么神圣。所以你会很安全的。是的。太好了。我想我们下次再见吧。汤姆。再见。如果我还……是的，我们会的。
Yep. See you, Dominic. See you back. Have a safe flight back. And I hope you don't get put into a hotel for 10 days at Heathrow. Thank you. That's more of a threat than a hope, I think, from you. You're going to be straight onto the border force.
好的。再见，多米尼克。再见。祝你飞行一路平安。希望你不会在希思罗机场被隔离在酒店里待上10天。谢谢。我觉得与其说是祝福，不如说是你的威胁。你马上就要去边境部队了。
See you, sir, man. All right. Okay. Bye-bye, everyone. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见，老兄。好的。好了。大家再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》，获取更多加更节目、抢先收听和无广告收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。